[Music]
hey folks welcome back to the Darkhorse
podcast live stream guest episode
2023 also known as
202.5 just because the one we just
finished was 202 oh yes and you guys
wouldn't let me enter this as a number
last year so we're just going to go with
like the guest ep the gift episodes are
not within the normal numbering scheme
yes they they it's an extra Dimension
orthogonal to oh it's such a grudge yeah
it's GNA come up every year okay well I
get it thank you for warning me um all
right so uh warning you well sure that
uh that i' I've I've caused a problem
with the numbering scheme oh this wasn't
you oh it was him oh oh excellent all
right that is a load off my mind so yeah
so here we are um ready to talk about um
about some some gifts gifts ideas and um
I will just say that um we get sent some
amazing things uh by by our by people in
our audience uh and it it's a little uh
loud for air so I didn't wear it during
my live stream but this is this
beautiful scarf um that and that was
just sent to me um by uh a woman
wonderful woman clearly uh in Oregon um
and she also made this amazing
uh sitting behind us uh which I don't
trust him I just I just love it and it's
like the sort of thing which if you
describe it to me I'd be like I don't
okay fine but it's a it's a felted
Critter dude uh and uh he's he's
completely freaking awesome yeah he's
really awesome and she made it entirely
and uh she does uh War us to keep it
away from the cats it looks like exactly
the sort of thing a cat would destroy
did she make it from wool pulled off of
people's eyes
eyes yes no does not seem like that sort
of woman at all seems cruel no no I
think it's good to remove the wool from
people's eyes the wool yes the wool that
has been pulled over people's eyes has
been removed and turned into felted
creatures like that that's what I'm
hoping I don't
know all right I've again over
complicated things maybe maybe um let's
just start um with one paragraph from
the piece that our friend Drew and I
wrote uh in advance of uh the holiday
season in 2021 for my substat called
from silk to pastries gifting Traditions
across time space and
species uh and I just want to read the
final paragraph from this if I can find
it there we go okay so you can show my
computer now uh so this is again from
silk to pastries gifting Traditions
across time space and species we talk
about frogs we talk about spiders we
talk about the Kung maybe we don't talk
about spiders um uh people in Iran uh
lots lots of good stuff um um but the
very end okay I just want to share this
one
paragraph gifts therefore that indicate
true attention to the other a knowledge
of what drives them what skills and
interests they have what they are
thinking about are more likely to be
well received than our generic gifts
unlike in Iran the weird world does not
tend to explicitly recognize the
difference between private gifts and
public ones as such we move between
those boundaries with little awareness
that they might even exist gifts that
are not mere Commodities indicate
attention to the gifted particularly
well
the promise of a shared experience a
walk together a simple meal or a fancy
one a trip handcrafted gifts in part
because they cannot be easily replicated
in part because they're often of higher
quality than their mass-produced
counterparts are lovely as well and
Gifts made with your own hands with your
own thoughts and warmth built right in
are the least fungible of all this makes
them high risk what if the recipient
doesn't like the Hat you made or the
bowl the jewelry or the cake with high
risk comes the potential for high reward
though and even if something is not
exactly to The recipient's Taste that
does not negate the affection and effort
that goes into creating something with
your own
hands beautiful so um perfectly in
keeping if I may have my screen back um
to figure out where we're going next
um we can either um jump right into uh
Wooden Spoons and reading material or
something on your list yeah I would like
to I would like to start actually with a
gift from us to our audience which is a
an odd sort okay um but uh a playlist
and this is following from a
conversation that you have all heard us
have about the importance
of faired stuff whether that is a shared
origin story shared narratives of
History shared musical tradition and we
have lamented the fact that as much as
there's lots of great stuff available to
us let's say musically uh we don't share
very much and that is I think tearing us
apart
so uh we have a playlist of songs that
are selected for various reasons some of
them they're very particular reasons
that they're included um but all of them
just to be clear I don't even know
what's on this playlist so you created
this yeah I I'll admit to creating this
um I don't I don't worry that you're
going to put something other that I'm
going to object to I just like we we
didn't actually create this you cre it's
been played for you you have not
objected to anything so
um so in any case it is a Darkhorse
playlist um the thought is it would be
great these are these are songs that I
at least think are worth your time uh I
am very lyric focused so I believe they
are they all stand up to scrutiny at the
level of lyrics and I would suggest at a
personal level that I think it's very
valuable to learn to sing stuff even if
you're just going to sing to yourself
even if you're not going to sing the
whole song and you're just going to
there's one stanza that particularly
strikes you um figure out what it says I
would advise you to look up the lyrics
of all of these songs so that you know
what's being said and then find that
stanza and then it's always difficult
unless you're especially musically
gifted to sing it right the first time
um it takes practice and uh anyway I
would advise that you know if we all
came to know these songs together I
think we'd be better off and I can't I
can't defend it beyond that um but
anyway do you want to show the uh you
said you wanted me not to show it is in
the description um Can can you show the
cover uh I don't really care
what yes I can
show so this is a Spotify playlist that
Zach has made
available um and it is labeled Darkhorse
23 and to scroll through it no okay can
you show the cover does it allow you to
do that uh not in this okay that's fine
um so we will make the link available um
and anyway you
can peruse it as you like oh I will just
give one caveat there are uh several
songs at the end that are a bit edgier
and I did that because if you're driving
your kids in the car and those songs
aren't ones you want to play or if
they're too edgy for you um then you can
just stop at the point that you get to
those songs at the end what does edgy
mean in this context well
um the content may be Advanced are you
talking about um words that people may
not want to hear or or
ideas
um there's a certain amount of Darkness
there's a certain amount of conceptual
Advanced and there is a certain C amount
of risk in
genre um okay so conceptual Advanced I
would say there's no there's no reason
for a trigger warning right like if you
get there and you don't understand it
you don't like it whatever it doesn't
matter I don't think there's a reason
for a trigger warning for adults but um
suffice it to say those were put at the
end so that if conceptual advances or
like mature
themes yeah tell you what songs there
yeah yeah um let's put it this way there
is a song uh here that I quite like and
cannot explain why it has not become
welln amongst uh dissident minded people
it has it has reached a certain number
but lots of people who I would have
thought would know this song very well
have never encountered it and anyway
it's a hip-hop song which would
ordinarily not be to my taste the song
is very much to my taste um but it
covers it it's basically a has the
themes of hipop musically no it's not
even the themes of hip-hop okay it
musically presents an
argument beautifully oh I would also say
that it is among three songs for which
it is important the song stands up on
its own as music but I believe it is
actually part of a type of art that goes
beyond music that the visual
presentation is integral it's not like a
song that somebody appended a video to
the video was conceptualized by the
artist in this case I'm talking about
Aaron Francis also true for five times
August but in those cases Aaron Francis
and five times August I would say um you
definitely need to go through the video
once for one thing it will present you
with the lyrics and it will do so in a
way that is artfully integrated it's not
close captioned it's artistically cool
um but anyway those songs are at the end
so if you find they are not to your
taste or you don't want to play them for
your guests or your kids you can just
stop at some
point all right
awesome
um okay how about spoons and books fair
enough spoons and books um I love
handcarved Wooden Spoons as you know uh
and as such I've ended up collecting
quite a few uh and I use we use most of
them like we don't we don't put them
aside and and never use them this was
actually given to me um when we left and
it's it's old and it's just beginning to
crack when we left Michigan by a friend
um who's I I think it was her
mother-in-law made it um and it still
got the yeah 2001 um was made in 2001 we
were gifted it to it in 2002 um so that
it the the virtue of handmade gifts is
that fondling them using them using them
to cook um in this case reminds you of
the person whereas
uh the more towards a commodity the gift
is the less likely the thing is to
remind you of that person because you've
run into it in many other contexts right
um so I would add something to it which
is obviously implied but um there is
also the fact of the handmade gift not
only reminding you of the person who
made it but that uh if the person made
it for youh then they also thought about
you and what you would think about it as
they were constructing it and so there
is a kind of um bonding in that process
Absol is fundamental and not reproduced
by regular normal gift culture these
days yes exactly so um there are many
Artisan um spoon makers now um but I
have been lucky to uhu be in contact
with EMT uh vandre is I hope I'm not
butchering your name um and he has a
spoon of the month club which I think is
just a a fantastic thing so this is one
of the spoons from his spoon of the
month club and I learned about his spoon
of the month club by by reading uh his
book which I believe he sent to us I may
have ordered I may have ordered I don't
actually remember for sure you can show
my screen here uh it's called carving
out a living on the land lessons in
resourcefulness and craft from an
unusual Christmas tree farm um he is an
unlikely
unexpected
um purveyor I guess of Christmas trees
and he and um gosh it's been a while
since I read the book but I think wife
uh run this Farm together and um growing
Christmas trees for people wasn't the
thing that he thought he'd be doing but
this is what um what land and um and
real honest physical work presented
itself and then he also does things like
um like make make these spoons so um
this book is fabulous um for anyone who
might be interested in not just um you
know a true story of a man working the
land but for me I actually found it
really useful uh in terms of you know
what it is to find yourself an unlikely
entrepreneur like oh my God he's running
a business now and there are all these
things and like how do you get your
stuff together um so it's it's
interesting from that perspective too um
and then no keep keep it on my screen
for a little bit here
um Chelsea Green is the publisher of uh
vra's book and I would say if you're
looking for
um if you're looking for gifts for a
book lover in your life they're um many
many amazing small Publishers um but I
want to just bring your attention to two
of them today Chelsea Green Chelsea
Green excuse me being one of them and
here's just their um larger
site um where they're actually they
actually have a 35% off every purchase
right now again this like this episode
there's nothing we're getting paid for
everything is uh we're presenting um in
entirely because we think that you might
enjoy it um but they have
um they do an incredible diversity of
types of books everything from sort of
homesteading and um alternative ways of
heating your home um to uh I believe
they republished Celia farber's um
serious Adverse Events um so you know
they're doing um a ton of excellent work
and then another small publisher is uh
Goden I think or it's godine I actually
have no idea how to pronounce their
their name um but they've got a lot of
very small like both you know nature
writing uh but uh just surprising
surprising books I'm even going to try
to classify um what it is that they're
doing but another publisher that is uh
worth worth your attention for sure uh
and in terms of reading material just
two more things um this is one I
recommended last year this is um Tara
Couture's uh slowdown Farmstead
substack uh which is fantastic she
writes about at this point she and her
husband are growing absolutely
everything um on their land
in Ontario I believe
um uh that they eat so they're they're
eating they're eating nothing from from
offsite which is incredible not far
north um but she's just uh a remarkable
writer and human being and um thoughtful
across so many domains I highly
recommend that uh as as a gift to
someone um you could of course consider
Natural Selections as well oh no two
more pieces of reading two more pieces
of reading
um there is um and so you can take down
my screen at this point um there is this
I'm going to lose that aren't I and then
all will be lost there's this book which
we continue to recommend hun gatherers
Guide to the 21st century Evolution the
challenges of Modern Life um I don't
have the versions of most of the other
languages that's been published in but I
do have French I have
French a little more a little more yeah
and I'm not again I'm not gonna
no
oh oh boy 21st I I say 21st in French I
say I didn't prepare at all and then I'm
not going to try to pronounce this but
you are um this is this is uh this is
the French this French that was the
French this is the Czech version this is
great not only for people who are
citizens of the Czech Republic but for
anybody who speaks Czech
MH that's a hilarious joke because the
only people who speak Czech yeah are
citizens of the Czech this we're just so
our book's been published in many
languages I don't know more than 20 at
this Point um and this is the the newest
on the list but and we've talked about
having just been in Prague for the the
baptism baptism of the book but it's
just super thrilling it's actually it's
a bestseller in the Czech Republic still
and um and yes this may be of little
interest to you if you don't speak check
but they've actually added a bunch of
original art in here frog yeah um every
chapter gets a little piece of original
art um I don't even know what is that I
don't know what chapter that's about
yeah yeah oh no this is the sex oh this
is a bow bird it's the sex chapter nice
um so anyway yes this book was lovingly
translated into Czech which uh we
appreciate we obviously can't check all
of the other versions but this version I
have no doubt was done Rel yeah I think
so too oh
um other piece of uh reading material
that you should seriously consider
getting for yourself or gifting to other
people uh is this fine fine publication
it's America's only newspaper so if you
think that there are others you're wrong
um and frankly if you've read any of the
other things that are passing for
newspapers you will know all already
that there aren't any others left um
this is County Highway uh it's uh this
is the third issue that I'm holding in
my hands it comes out uh every two
months uh and it's not available online
you got to hold it so you can um you can
find it in some boy book stores feed
stores record record stores across the
country um but the best way to know that
you're going to get it is to subscribe
online and then uh you'll get some um
some regular columns from Amanda Fortini
this this week this month's this issues
is on dandelion it's actually totally
fascinating even if your first reaction
is dandelion what um I have a column
called field notes in County Highway um
there's often writing from uh David
Samuels and Walter karna in this one um
one of my favorites in this particular
EP episode why I can't issue
uh is Malibu versus noou why socal's
surfing Paradise stinks um by it turns
out someone that well I guess you didn't
but that I went to high school with um
you were just you started later later
and he was a couple years older than us
um and there's a big music section in
the back there's actually three
different articles on on or three
different page three whole pages on on
music it's fabulous it's America's only
newspaper seriously consider it
subscribe subscribe yeah um I got more
but you want to try something out so I
had kind of a a a a theme and it's
actually perfectly consistent with what
you read and my thought was this is this
is me as I've gotten uh older and I
think wiser about life and I'm realizing
that there
is I think you should consider the fact
that you live on a planet that has been
damaged yes but is still AB absolutely
full of Miracles and most times folks
who are uh devoted uh thinkers about
Evolution don't use that term but the
fact is it is full of Miracles they're
all around and that you can give access
to them and you can um facilitate seeing
them and you can in the best case um you
can join somebody in going and looking
at these things and I just don't think
there's anything better so I wanted to
just provide some sort of examples of
what I'm talking about one of
them uh the uncu trip that we went on is
something that I know has tremendous
value because I know how many times I
have stopped to think about it in the
aftermath it really uh affected me and
us and they are absolutely not paying us
to talk about them in this episode but I
thought I would show some of the stuff
that I managed to capture on our
adventure because it would give people
uh a sense you know it's obviously not
an inexpensive gift um but it uh is
something that pays back tremendous
dividends so would you show my screen
Zach so I just wanted to show some stuff
uh here we have uh a sea otter this is a
picture taken you'll note that we are
down at water level because this is
taken from a kayak in the rain uh and
that's a pretty amazing thing to be this
close to um such a marvelous animal in
you know real weather
uh yes you're moving the cursor off the
end yeah but anyway um that was a pretty
great experience and we had many such
encounters um
uh with otters and other creatures down
at eye level like that there were some
spots where there were like several
dozen sea otters yeah there were there
were you couldn't see several dozen at a
time but the way like you could tell
that you were surrounded by more than
two dozen and uh otters with their
babies which is a particularly
remarkable thing to see in this case uh
this is a grizzly bear um that was uh
this was taken from the shore of our
ship um here is a oh this photo looks
better on my screen than yours but this
is an otter with a baby
um here we have a
puffin um and here we've got some doll's
porpus which doll's porpus is like a it
has the coloration of an orca and they
love to ride the bow waves of ships and
so anyway in the middle of dinner one
day we picked up a pod of dolls porpuses
and I leapt up and grabbed my camera and
hung over the front of the boat um and
Tred to capture them and uh anyway here
I just wanted to show you this is a
series I'm going to run through and
you're going to see what these animals
were
doing here's Orca that we encountered um
bald eagle leaving its nest I don't know
I've forgotten what bird this is angry
little bird this was also taken from
kayak we hether and I kayaked right up
to the shore and saw quite a number of
interesting
birds um here we have uh so forgotten
what that is here we've got a humpback
whale um these guys were hanging out on
a little Iceberg these are harbor seals
um
and uh this is a photograph I
struggled I knew that this was possible
and I decided I was going to try to
capture it and it worked out better than
ID hoped so I wanted the glacier this is
the face of a glacier um uh meeting the
water and these are Arctic turns which
happen to be migrating through at the
time these are animals that migrate from
one pole to the other and if you zoom in
on that photograph you see that this
Arctic turn is carrying a small fish and
you can even see its eye the fish's eye
yeah it's crazy it's so good anyway
lovely and here's a bald eagle the ship
passed and so you're pretty close to uh
looking eye to eye with it um back whale
again saw multiple
of some some kind of shore bird yeah
Shorebirds
uh these were uh pigeons goats um not
pigeons no oh and here
I'm going to show this is I started
taking what I called video
postcards so the scenery looked like
this uh day after day after day so
anyway lots of gorgeous stuff to see um
here is yet one more SE otter super
close
up oh our oyster catchers hilar that
allowed me to approach them and they
squawked at me uh or otter of babies
anyway so that is one example of
uncruise and where it can take you um
the company was lovely both senses of
the term both the operation that took us
out there took great care of us the
people that decided to go on such an
adventure were very game to get on
kayaks and go hiking and all of this
anyway um it's a cool thing and it's
obviously not a cheap thing but um
there's a discount code uh for Darkhorse
uh viewers we will link it and um you
could go see once in a lifetime stuff
with people that you love and uh there's
no way that it's not worth it yeah
absolutely yep uh Zach you want to show
us some stuff from the store yeah yeah
uh you might want to talk about it while
I show it yeah no we won't just let it
be
quiet so uh we mentioned in the live
stream we got this new one cut that
out uh which I think speaks for itself
let's hope the world listens got lot of
stuff blueberries because accidents
happen um be easier to
yeah very very nice uh Jake's micro
Pizza of course oh yeah Dad you want to
speak a little bit on our uh in-house
Pizza yes our uh our new uh Gourmet
Pizza venture um these are I'm glad you
decide to make it Gourmet is it organic
it is organic it is hypoallergenic sure
it is guaranteed for life and it is your
life or its life uh both any life all
life it's guaranteed as long as there is
life there will be Jake micro a
universal guarantee a universal
guarantee is amazing is that not
remarkable yeah I can't believe you got
insurance for this well the thing is um
it's a whole different world when you're
dealing in uh microscop Foods sure I
would think so yes so anyway um Jake's
micro Pizza is not only delicious and uh
not as nutritious as it might be but you
know you can pick up your nutrition
elsewhere you can get your
micronutrients from Jake's micro Pizza I
don't think you can you can't get very
many of them at a time but um but it is
uh it is delightful and uh geometrically
accurate oh good yeah but it is is eight
slices per pie or 12 there are eight you
know have you get pizzas and the guy
clearly half has it there are eight well
cut slices they're thoroughly cut you
won't be tearing it cheese goes one way
and pepper goes the other yeah or you
get a piece it's like there's not enough
I don't have enough of the perimeter for
the size SLI like that what going on
here laser cut laser laser cut which
cauterizes the cheese at the edges of
the slices so they are um you won't cut
yourself don't cheese bed right exactly
um so anyway it is excellent pizza it is
also capable because the slices are so
small it is capable of alleviating some
of the burdens of mask mandate because
you can just keep eating the stuff
because it is going to take you a while
to get enough like I'm I'm still feeling
peckish even I'm five hours into Jake's
micro Pizza still feel a little package
not satisfying and therefore you can
just keep eating and you buy them in
those unending bags right just it goes
on and on it goes on that much we know
in definitely deep bags of Jake's micro
pizza and uh anyway uh it's uh it's
great and it it anticipates the return
of mass mandates which um you know most
pizzas don't anticipate anything right
pizza tends not to be forward thinking
but this pizza is
correct yes the world's only Forward
Thinking Pizza exactly that's the there
it is yeah yeah lots of other cool stuff
here too so much other cool stuff uh
settle up the direwolves we ride tonight
lie to a tyrant both of our sons have
lie to a tyrant hoodies which they wear
around and yeah um and uh and even just
the um the dark I just got a Darkhorse
hoodie in this nice navy color lovely
excellent um yeah there's lots of cool
stuff here cool you want to be a little
bit snarky on any number of issues
exactly yeah we got your snark for you
yeah yeah yeah all right
um let's see how
about you have some more things yes um
let's let's talk about
oh okay yeah let me let me let me do the
rest of what I wanted to do here um well
I forgot when I was talking about books
I wanted to mention as I always do book
darts yeah um these if you haven't heard
me talk about book darts I don't I I
don't know that I want to repeat myself
to for those who already know what they
are um but they come in these beautiful
little tins this one happens to have
that famous uh Japanese tsunami wave on
it um and they are the happens to be a
mixed metal batch so I've got three
different colors of book darts in here
and you can any book you can be reading
along pretending that you read check for
instance like oh that right there yeah I
want to be able to come back to that
section even though I have no idea what
it says in this case because I don't in
fact recheck um but you uh you fix it uh
to the page and you close it and it
closes flat and you can see it you can
see it from the side I don't know if you
can see it from the side but when you
are holding a book that has been book
darted up which many books that I own
are uh you can immediately see from the
side okay there like two or 20 spots in
this book uh that I want to come back to
you don't end up doing any permanent
damage to the book um this is of course
for people who actually still prefer to
have books in hand I have always
preferred to have books in hand now that
we see actual books being changed by the
Publishers and the powers that be I feel
even more um forward thinking like our
pizza um for having insisted on having
just rows and rows and you know
bookshelves and bookshelves and
bookshelves of actual books um but no
matter how many I have yet to reach the
limit of a book for book darts wherein
it no longer laid flat like they're that
thin I it's just an amazing product that
the book darts um I'm not going to
actually leave that in let you
reversibly highlight a book but that
that means that the book can go
permanently back on your shelf in its
highlighted form or if it's part of a
research project it can be book darted
into until you're done with the research
project and if you know if it's a
library book you can book Dart up a
library book and um not piss off your um
Librarians yes I would uh one caution do
not mix up your book darts with your
Jake's micro pizza that's dangerous no
and these are in fact um this is um I'd
say it's is it five for forers of
magnitude larger I'd say it's
400 orders of magnitude Jake's Pizza is
quite small I guess
okay um couple couple three four four
more four more products if now that
we're talk about products a little bit
Yeah book darts product um I've talked
about this before this is um epic dermis
from uh Pharaoh Pharaoh life it comes
with a cute little pig um pig sticker
and this is lard and Tallow based um
skin care this happens to be their
newest product um which we I we I got
for the first time right before we went
to Alaska actually on the uncruise trip
and Alaska in April and May you
especially if you're spending most of
your time outside uh can be chafing and
this stuff is Magic the ingredients are
lard Tallow honey bergamont wild orange
basil and black Spruce essential oils
those last four are just essential oils
basically to make it smell good
bergamont wild orange basil and black
Spruce the three ingredients that are
doing good for your skin are lard Tallow
and honey it feels feels great it smells
great it's fantastic stuff epic dermis
is the beautiful name of the product and
it's from uh Pharaoh fa r r o w which
was a sponsor of ours but we are not um
this is this is for free um we are
recommending this you have something to
say and unlike Jake's micro pizza if you
do need to eat it even though that's not
its really intended purpose it has lots
and lots of calories and is fully I
imagine you could um you read the
ingredients yeah uh I don't I feel like
you it would actually cheaper to buy
steak if you want to get your calories
from I'm saying in an emergency if it's
all you have and you need to go another
day okay note to I'm going to hide this
so that you don't know where it lives
yeah we don't know what he defines as an
emergency exactly the stores are closed
I'm feeling a little peckish and I'm
chock full out of chock out of he a that
could easily be counted as as an
emergency exactly yeah okay three three
more uh three more things here um we
have talked before about giant herbs and
and t uh wonderful herbalist in uh
Portland uh who actually we've never met
um but we've been in contact with and
who actually sent um some of his uh some
of his healing tonics and herbs for you
when you were recently sick with with is
certainly covid um and so I just have
brought out a couple he makes these CH
he makes Bitters and I'm just going to
read from a couple of them they are
quite something at many different levels
they're fantastic they're unusual and
he's got text on all of them that is
often hilarious so this is organiz chai
um this is a lapsang such I'm probably
butchering these words lapsang suang
Sichuan pepper and fennel chai and this
is uh basically named for Joe Rogan uh
he says on the front one man revealing
evil one interview at a time it begins
with all of us a world of individuals
with the ability to critically think and
um on the back each able to make our own
difference or be content to be told how
to think the choice is ours there is no
easy path to Freedom ask questions talk
to your neighbors build community and
most importantly be kind to one another
one world all of us together we're
organize PS cancelling only makes us
stronger so that's awesome um it's all I
mean he has such a huge number of these
ches let me just read one more there's
also a Darkhorse chai I just didn't I
think we're out I I didn't find that
when I went looking just now whiffer
chai a galong
lemongrass and ginger chai if at first
you don't get antibodies try and try
again a little bit doesn't go a long way
in fact you will need more before three
months are
up um and on the
back that's great for us but not so
great for your tax dollars this chai
does not stop contraction transmission
or sterilize anything we actually don't
know what the long-term effects of
drinking chai are but if adults can
drink it we think kids should have it
too if our Palace of the FDA came
through for us we could have said secret
ingredients from 2021 to 2076
yep um and then the bitters are also
amazing these are my two favorite he
makes huge number of bitters but these
are my two favorites um revolutionary
evolutionary revolutionary evolutionary
bitters mole spice cocktail bitters uh
which have in
them um tequila cacao cinnamon and other
spices in the Revolutionary evolutionary
and kakano cocktail bitters
um so and this the flavor notes on this
are quick cacao front note followed by a
wickedly spicy finish it's got cacao
habanero hibiscus and other spices
utterly fantastic utterly fantastic yeah
it is fantastic um yeah the the spicy
ches in particular are uh so good one of
them yeah I I love all of them that I've
that I've had and I don't like and one
of those ches that I read has fennel in
it I'm not usually a big fan of fennel
but he does just brilliantly um speaking
of
drinks uh I think last last time I
talked about a couple of shrubs that
were being made up here on the islands I
have since found one in that is being
made in nearby Bellingham I I found I
found these people at the anacor art
fair this summer and I cannot get enough
so shrub is basically a fruit infused
fruit infused vinegar they make their
raw apple cider vinegar themselves and
then they Infuse it and um basically you
put some in in sparkling water uh for an
alcohol free drink if you want a drink
with alcohol then you add alcohol it's
not that
hard got it yeah you got it and then if
that's what you're doing you can also
add some Bitters and boy fantastic
combinations but um they these guys
shrub Farm uh out of Bellingham and they
ship probably not anywhere but any place
that I've thought to ship
um they have lots of amazing flavors
here are two of my favorites this is
shiso and citrus shiso is I forgotten
and it doesn't say on here no here it
does uh shiso
and citrus shrub they say has a global
sole in Hometown Roots shiso is a
Japanese herb which adds a berry-like
burst of flavor to goddess dressing
Botanical gen tonics and refreshing
sparklers and it's also grown locally
here in Mount Vernon the shiso even
though it's a Japanese herb and then
this is my absolute favorite of theirs
Ginger and Hawaiian chili shrub so
that's two kinds of hot that's two kinds
of spicy and they use real Ginger and so
it like settles in the bottom there's
this like white uh gingery deliciousness
in the bottom and this will wake you up
if you're if you're suffering from micro
sleep swell driving try some of this
Ginger and Hawaiian chili shrub totally
utterly amazing you know people drink so
much generic factory made garbage and
this is just the opportunity to you know
to create a drink that's your own you
know figuring out what to mix it with um
and anyway it's just it's it's a whole
different ball game yeah I mean it's
obviously you can you can drink cheaper
yep um but uh I don't think you can do
some more deliciously and with regard to
the shrubs and the chai but um you know
they're healthy they're they're good for
you the shrubs are apple cider vinegar
which is absolutely good for you uh and
um and it's just delightful so one more
one more recent discovery in terms of a
product that was local where I bought it
and it's not local to us now uh but it's
it's Bjorn's bees um this is just a
little little jar they have these jars
which
are I don't know how big they are 3
ounces and then they have these 10 ounz
jars um this is they have a number of
Honeys and other products uh you can buy
the stuff online um but this is their
lemon honey and they they're based in or
at least they have a store in Golden in
Golden Colorado which I spent a day in
when I was in Denver recently and um I
bought a little little jar like this of
the lemon honey I was feeling just a
little tiny bit under the weather like
my my throat tends to you know go before
anything else does and just a little bit
of lemon
honey does the trick sounds delightful
so good and they have propolus honey
they have they have they have these um
explicitly medicinal Honeys too which
still taste amazing you can do all the
normal things you would with honey um
some of them they say if you want the
full medicinal um stuff don't cook it so
just you know eat it raw um but anyway
that's Bjorn bees with their lemon honey
and other Honeys shrub farm with their
apple cider vinegar shrubs and um giant
herbs and tea out of Portland with their
ches and Bitters and other good stuff
and all of that will be um in the show
notes with links cool
not I was GNA make a spelling joke I
don't know how to spell Links of the uh
fed variety yeah you do I do I is a l
ynx yeah yeah I do know how to spell it
God yeah no if I if we get a links I'm
not putting in the show notes I'm
keeping the links to myself keep yes I
imagine yeah um all right so I wanted to
continue on the theme of uh giving
Miracles and really best if you share
those Miracles if you take people
somewhere or show them something but I
kind of wanted to uh just point
out
that the Miracles exist at every scale
and every level of difficulty and one
thing I've increasingly tried to do is
everywhere I go even if it's someplace
I'm not especially excited to go if I'm
invited somewhere let's say and I have
to give a talk but I'm not somewhere I
try to figure out where I can find cool
stuff that I've never seen nearby and I
was in Fort Lauderdale some months ago
and I actually found a little
um little Waterway right there in town
and it was full of all kinds of
interesting stuff I didn't I don't have
any pictures of it because I didn't have
a camera with me at the time um but uh
couple things one I wanted to suggest
fewer and fewer people have binoculars I
actually neglect to take my binoculars
to Florida
um and I was kicking myself the whole
time I needed binoculars and I had I had
too much stuff with me and I dispensed
with them but binoculars don't have to
be incredibly expensive um and there's a
diminishing returns to it right you know
the difference between a $50 pair of
binoculars and a $200 pair of binoculars
is
substantial um and you know that might
be the same difference between a $200
and th000 pair of binoculars but the
ability to get in close with what you're
looking at changes the experience
dramatically um you are not necessarily
looking for the highest magnification
that's the error I always make um yeah
no you don't you don't need it about 10
buy is about as much as you want 12 by
actually makes it hard to unless it's
image stabilized there are image
stabilized even so it's just it's harder
to find especially if you're looking at
Birds if you're if looking at things
that are moving fast or radically or
both across a landscape it's harder to
find them um the more magnified you are
that is quite true eight bu are actually
great 10 bu is sort of The Sweet Spot
that either eight or 10 is really where
you want to be and the second number uh
in so these are 10 by 42s um is how much
how much light they gather so you can
get a really nice Optical set that you
know is a lot smaller than this but the
point is the point in the evening at
which it's not useful anymore is much
earlier yeah 10x 42 is that's that's
that's sweet right there yeah you you do
want that second number to be high yeah
and these These are it's not a
denominator right yeah yeah it's it's a
multiplier um but anyway these are not
incredibly fancy but the number of times
that this is exactly what I want uh is
most of the time yeah I I will I know I
know they're not your favorite but I I
will just make a pitch for um the
binoculars that I've had forever that I
absolutely adore Y and that until I had
them I couldn't quite make binoculars
work for for me I think I've just
matured so I can make a lot of
binoculars work for me now but um it's
uh Viper Vortex um Viper I think is the
make because you just got a different
pair of vipers in Alaska actually I
don't love they they're they're uh they
were like discounted they were like and
like anyway um but but the vortex ones
are fancy they are expensive uh and
they're um but they are if you if you
are looking for an amazing pair of
binoculars and can spend money I find
them to be the most extraordinary yeah
um okay so then I wanted to can you show
my screen again I just wanted to sort of
show that there's sort of different
levels that Miracles come at every scale
and every difficult of scene these
happen to be ecuadoran grasshoppers so
that's hard to get to but the point is
it's grasshoppers right these are not uh
Jaguars um and these guys were
fascinating to watch and as a
mammologist how do you know that they're
fascinating that they're not Jaguars oh
interesting uh they lack any of the
synapomorphies of the Mia let alone
Jaguars um so here's a spider that was
sitting in the on a rock in the middle
of a river um you know uh this is
probably six inches across fascinating
creature tent making bats which you're
going to have a hard time finding though
if you go to a tropical forest in the
neotropics you'll be walking by them
um now here's this is super difficult to
get to this is a pygmy marma set um
which is I think the smallest monkey on
Earth um and seeing them requires uh
somebody who knows where to find them
um Cayman used to be much more common
where we have been going in the Amazon
they decreased for reasons we don't
know um here's
Watson uh the incredible gut
fermenting gut
fermenting Birds uh again you need to
know where to look um but not hard to
see if somebody can point you to a place
where they live um ah so these photos
may be out of order this is a sea turtle
in the
galopagos here is the Penguin that we
were talking about in the main great
personality the great personality yeah
with that picture I
beautiful penguin but they do have a
great
personality way God the color of that
water looks like he's in a swimming pool
yeah it sure does yeah here's a uh
Marine iguana in the gpag and this is
from the series um that you have as the
banner on the YouTube channel yes yeah
exactly it might still be or it was uh
here is a sea lion cleaning his feet yep
okay and then um is this going to be
colia yeah this is Colombia uh our
friend benois um after he had me down to
a conference to give a talk um uh took
me to uh Pon which is up in the
mountains a cliff area lots of stuff to
see oh man that's glorious look at these
these is this is all Columbia yep um and
now this is Santa Cruz this is stuff you
can see right off uh this I took this
one off the pier in Santa Cruz guys are
f all around um and this is uh right
here in the San Juan Islands these are
foxes there uh they were introduced to
control the rabbit population which was
introduced to feed the Lighthouse Keeper
but these things are actually not that
hard to see if you're here in the right
season you can see foxes any time of
year but uh in the spring the wild
puppies yeah the wild puppies
unbelievable they are just like could
they be any cuter right and so you
know there's no part of me that you know
the to see such a thing in person just
to Simply look with your own eyes and
see these creatures doing this um as if
you're not there is stunning and
possible and I would point out uh
although we haven't taken on cruise to
the San Juan Islands um they do come
here yeah they um so anyway but you you
you can also you can also come here
without yes an an unru there there are
so many amazing places to go and as you
pointed out you know I've never been to
Fort Lauderdale sounds like you got
there you didn't have much time you
weren't sure how to find anything
interesting and you found something
interesting and this is what both of us
do wherever we are and you know I have I
think I've mentioned this I have in my
organizational software a recurring
event um that shows up I don't remember
exactly what the periodicity is but it's
less than every two weeks um go
someplace you've never been now that's
hard now that we live on an island
because
is much more finite than a Mainland um
but just even set foot some place you
haven't
been regularly yeah it is literally eye
opening and if if I I don't know how to
describe it exactly but if you set
yourself the goal of seeing some
creature that you've never looked at
before this is possible for pretty much
everybody pretty much everywhere and the
point is you know if it takes you know
if you're in some place if you're in the
middle of LA
you may have trouble doing this you have
to get to the outskirts but once you get
to the outskirts it becomes possible
again and um
that they're all miracles right yeah um
so here actually you show my screen
again you know here's an example this is
a simple bee approaching a simple
flower and once you saw the flower you
could be pretty sure this was going to
happen this is a wild flower here in the
San Juan was this this was wild this was
this was not the one that volunteered in
our garden no this was uh this was an
American Camp yeah that's right um and I
just saw this flower growing on this
Windswept Hill and I was like you know
if I sit there I bet you some
interesting stuff comes and you know it
was an interesting photographic
challenge to try to catch it and get the
be in focus and all that but but anyway
the point is Miracles everywhere they
really are absolutely um and here this
is uh my recent trip to the Keys um this
is on uh actually this is on the wall of
Fort Zachary Taylor in Us Fort Zachary
Taylor that is a beautiful lizard it is
a beautiful lizard he was he gorgeous
quite enchanting yeah um and then here's
the key deer that we were talking about
so anyway you know there's stuff to go
see and mostly
people because they don't think of it as
a special as it is they don't think to
go pursue it but if you you know you you
can give your your life an upgrade and
you can give those you wish to give a
gift to a life upgrade by just really
just tapping into the Miracles that are
all around you not declaring themselves
ever yeah be be here now and open your
senses and
uh don't assume that you already know
what you're going to see yep exactly and
I would also just point out um uh
there's a saying amongst photographers
um the very best camera in the world is
the one you have with you MH and we all
now carry or almost all of us carry an
incredibly powerful camera it's not what
you want uh to capture Wildlife far away
that's it's tough to do with such a
small lens but there's a lot you can
capture um with such a camera and I just
was going to suggest this one other
thing in terms of inexpensive gifts a
case that allows you to take your phone
which is somewhat waterproof but not
great when it's exposed when it's
submerged um
this it matters a lot um this was a
relatively inexpensive case that
actually has a pretty high quality um
set of uh the plastic does not interfere
with the quality of the photos and you
can submerge it and you've got an
underwater camera you know it's not
going to you know if you Dove to 20 feet
it wouldn't work but mostly you're up
near the surface anyway if you're
snorkeling yeah if you're snorkeling or
if you you know hop into a river and
there's all kind kind of interesting
stuff swimming snakes and you know all
sorts of uh things you might capture so
anyway yeah as much as I love snakes I
don't actually recommend swimming with
snakes so much depends on the snake you
know it's not a bit there are lots of
snakes that are no
problem this is not the side of the
argument I expected to be
on um swimming snakes are cool some of
them are they look amazing yeah they
just uh a lot of the a lot of the
swimming snakes you've seen a swimming
snake in salt water they tend to be very
docile but those are elapids those are
related to cobas um so they probably
won't uh bite you but if they do you
done you were probably asking for it no
you my
god um so did I feel like I'm I feel
like I've forgotten something but uh I
think we're good yeah D at least does he
I'm going
have you right yeah okay wow let's let's
prepare to be surprised here we go
is it wooden Fork oh yes I was going to
suggest um this is a an image by Bob
Moran who has become a uh extraordinary
voice for the dissidents in the covid
era he's got some very powerful images
this is my favorite of them um the
mother standing firm against the
vaccinating demon protecting her child
is would be a natural thing to do but
anyway
um there is something to the gift of Art
and there's something to supporting
artists who have stood up against a
mighty censorious tide um and anyway Bob
Moran is a good one yeah so we will
leave a link to his site absolutely
um in the uh in the show notes
fantastic all right all right we're
there I think we are there we're there
um so we'll be back next week and we
will do a Q&A next week it's been a
couple weeks since we've done it since
this replaced that this week M there was
a lot of thises and thats but you
followed along yes no you didn't I I on
the on the replay I will I will have
followed along you will have after the
replay replay yeah yes absolutely
excellent all right well we will see you
next week or you will see us next week
or you may choose not to I don't know um
but please do uh we'll be back at 11:30
Pacific on Wednesday December something
uh I don't know what that's going to be
12th maybe uh someone has a calendar in
front of them it'll be a Wednesday yeah
uh and um yeah until we see you next
time be good to the ones you love eat
good food and get outside be well
[Music]
everyone
for